Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
There's a new house
the Dragon Season 2 teaser
that was released for the battle
at Rook's Rest
which is going to be one of the major
battles of season two.
There's a bunch of new footage
with some cool Easter Eggs,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
I'll be doing bonus videos during the off
season.
Episodes are still on track to release
next summer, though, despite the strikes.
That's only because most of the cast
are international actors.
They're not part of the unions. It's
actually striking.
Some of them are, but most of them are.
So they can continue filming
The footage is mostly of the Green Army
being led by Criston Cole, who's Aegon II
commander during this part of the dance,
the Dragons Targaryen Civil War.
It's still relatively early days
during the fighting,
but there have already been some minor
battles.
This is meant to be one of the major ones
early in the conflict.
Like major WTF moments.
pretty much all this teaser
and footage is from episode four.
That's when the actual battle
is going to take place.
In the footage you can see
Kristen Cole leading the Greens
through the woods in Rooks Rest here.
It's a scene of how Staunton
they declared for Rhaenyra.
And the blacks, like their house
here, is along the basically
because pretty much
all these houses declared for an era
the whole idea is that Lord
Staunton is trying to defend
against the Green Army,
which has about 3000 men and two dragons,
Sunfire and Vega, ridden by Aegon,
the second in Almond, who are both there
in at least at this point in the teaser
like here in the video, like this footage,
Rhaenys has shown up on her
Dragon Melees, yet
she's the only dragon
that shows up to this fight.
so the whole idea is that Lord
Staunton at this point is trying to defend
his castle at Rooks Rest with only
about 100 of his regular guards that he'd
normally have stationed at the castle.
Notice in the footage you can see
Kristen Cole yelling at Gwyn Hightower.
This is their stunt doubles in the scenes.
That's why it doesn't look exactly
like the regular actors, this.
What their faces in visual effects. Later.
But he's basically yelling at him
because he's not properly dressed
for the battle on the morning
that it actually begins.
Because they're preparing to lay siege
to the castle.
bigger reminder
because we haven't seen Gwyn Hightower
since the beginning of season one.
But if you remember during the tourney,
Daemon basically put him on his ass
he was Otto Hightower son Alicent's brother
the other really cool Easter egg here.
Zoom in enhance. This is Eddie Air.
He's playing one of the Hightower soldiers
here, one of the Green's soldiers.
He was also on Game of Thrones
on the main show during the Tower of Joy
flashbacks playing Gerald Hightower.
So the funny thing here is that he might
he might wind up playing
one of his ancestors during this show, but
we don't know exactly who he's playing.
Let me know in the comments
if you do think
that he's playing one of his ancestors.
and this is super important to zoom
in enhance you notice that Kristen Cole
or his stunt double is wearing the chain
of the hand around his neck.
The chain is a bunch of clasped hands,
as in hand of the king, like literal hand.
that's because at this time,
during the dance of the Dragons, Kristen
Cole had replaced Otto Hightower is Aegon
the seconds hand
because Aegon had gotten piston
Otto Hightower's
performance
during the dance of the Dragon.
So far, Normally Otto Hightower
would have been able to push Aegon around,
tell him what to do,
the same way that Tywin
Lannister was able to control Joffrey
because everyone was afraid of him.
Even Cersei was still afraid of him.
But as we get deeper into the seasons,
you start to see more parallels
between Joffrey and Aegon the second.
Now, Joffrey was a little crazier
than Aegon the second,
but again,
the second kind of bends in a Joffrey way
they started to tease this
at the end of season
one like he starts to go a little drunk
with the power
like it all starts to go to his head
just a little bit.
Whereas before
he just thought that he was complete trash
and would do whatever anybody told him,
particularly Alison,
the only difference with Joffrey, Searcy
and other people like Tywin around Joffrey
is that Joffrey rarely,
if ever, listened to, certainly like
I don't know if she was ever able
to actually control him.
there was like a brief hot second
when Alison was able to control
Aegon the second,
but the minute that the crown hit his head
and that's Aegon the conqueror
crown to that he's wearing then
things really go crazy and he just starts
doing whatever he wants to do.
Basically.
it what you see happen at the beginning
of the actual dance, the dragons,
when the actual battles
begin, One of Daemon's earliest acts
in the war was to take Herron
Hall with his dragon axes,
which is meant to be a big callback
to Aegon the conqueror burning Harrenal.
Demon loves those sorts of things,
like he's an old school Targaryen,
so he loves any comparison that anybody
would make to him to Aegon the conquer.
when Damian takes Herron Hall with Carax
sees a bunch of houses in the realm
side with the blacks.
We'll probably see a version of that
at the beginning of the season.
The first couple of episodes,
maybe episode two or so,
you remember at the end of season one,
Daemon kept telling Reinier in the War
Council around the map table that Herron
Hall was a key strategic position
because it allowed them to box the Greens.
And so they basically trying to claim
all these great houses,
all this territory around King's Landing,
if they can.
Right now, most of the houses
around the bay here support the black.
So they basically have them boxed
in on the right.
But that's why
Criston Cole is leading the Green Army,
two Rooks Reds to remedy that situation.
the idea is that
Daemon was so successful early in the days.
The Dance of the Dragons, it pisses acorn
the second off.
Who gets even matter?
Otto Hightower
when he tries diplomacy with Rhaenyra
in the blacks, which Aegon perceived
incorrectly as poor tactics.
there was a lot of conversation about this
between the characters during season one.
Like, No, no, no, let's talk this out.
We could figure this out
Aegon the second and pretty much
all the other people around him,
like Criston Cole, just want war.
I do.
Hightower mysteriously is trying.
Diplomacy is a tactic.
He kind of did that during season
one, though,
to so there is you have all these people
that want to avoid a civil war
because it'll just lead to the destruction
of both sides of the house.
And then you have a couple of people
within these great houses
that just want more war
Aegon winds up firing.
Otto Hightower
replaces him with Criston Cole,
who's every bit as nuts as Aegon is.
Look, you kind of saw
that happening
during the events of season one,
especially when he started cozying up
with Alison.
blood and cheese winds up happening, which
is supposed to go down in episode one.
No spoilers for that,
but it's a super WTF moment
and it's Demon's eye for an eye
retaliation.
In response to what happened at the end
of season one with Luther as an almond.
so most of the greens are hungry
for some kind of revenge,
like some kind of military action
against the blacks Criston Cole
takes a force of about 2400 men,
marches on Rosby and Stokeworth,
who were too close supporters of Rhaenyra.
They surrender their forces
in exchange for their lives
and basically their forces
add to the Green's
they take their now larger force
and lay siege to dusk and Dell.
They basically call it the sack of dusk.
And it was a port town.
So they burned all their ships.
And pretty much anybody
who was still loyal to the blacks,
a few of them joined sides with the Greens
after their success at duskendale
they pushed two rooks rest
where Criston Cole caught hope
to lay a trap for rear end.
Daemon expecting them to come to Lord
Staunton's aid, where he planned
to use their superior numbers
like vastly superior numbers into dragons
to kill them all, thinking it would end
the war What ended up happening,
though, is that only Rhaenys came towards
Staunton's eight on her Dragon Melees.
So it was a very one sided battle
and they didn't necessarily achieve
exactly what they had hoped.
there's a little bit of footage
of the Dragons here.
Like you can see
all these charred soldiers
on the ground here
that have been burned by Dragon Fire.
But mostly the dragons are visual effects,
not practical.
So they have a bunch of stand
ins for the dragon's heads.
So you see people walking around
with dragon heads on stakes here.
they're using a couple of different heads
to represent which dragons are here.
It's only meant to be sun
fire, vigor in melees.
The whole idea is that
males is a much quicker dragon in the air
than the other dragons.
And Rhaenys is much more experienced
in battle than the others.
As you can see,
there's a ton of collateral damage here.
In addition to each of the dragons
trying to roast the other forces alive.
The dragons are like nuclear weapons.
A single dragon
could take out an entire army
unless that other army was really handy
with the scorpion.
And during this period in history,
because dragons were so common.
everyone had scorpions.
It wasn't like the main show,
Game of Thrones, where Qyburn
had to pull the plans for the Scorpions
out of the Citadel, dust them off
and build a bunch of new ones.
And remember,
this is the targaryens fighting each other
like a civil war within the family.
So each side
knew how to train their armies
to fight dragons,
even though it had been so long since
anyone had actually needed to do that
in the realm with a few exceptions.
Thus, a lot of the soldiers
in the Green Army here are not experienced
in dragon combat
the way that they need to be,
which is why males
who is a much quicker dragon and Rhaenys,
a much more experienced fighter
because she lived through
McGuire The Cruel in a lot of the wars
during that period was able to basically
hold her own against 3000 soldiers
into dragons
They'll deal with the aftermath
of the battle in episode five,
there was a teaser for episode
five a couple of months ago.
I already did a much bigger video for it,
so I'll link Lincoln at the end of this
and down to the description below
because it also gets super crazy,
Most of the footage here is the Green Army
marching on the castle
with their siege weapons, getting ready
to actually bust in the doors
The other major thing that just happened
is they confirm
Robert Rhodes will play silver
denys is one of the dragonseeds
that were near, and Daemon
tried to find for the available dragons
they have access to on Dragonstone.
They're trying to find
as many dragonriders as possible.
Silver Denys has this funny backstory
that they might wind up
using for a big punchline moment
during the series.
He's a very arrogant version
of someone, say, like Gendry or Jon Snow,
like a bastard
who thinks very highly of themselves
as opposed to Gendry and Jon Snow.
They didn't really want to play up
their parentage that much until much,
much later when they were forced to SILVER
Denis grew up on Dragonstone during Core
Targaryen era and would often boast
that he was the bastard son of Megara
the cruel like it was a big deal for him
and he let everybody know about it.
they needed anyone with
any kind of valyrian blood in their veins
capable of bonding with a dragon
no matter how much.
So he qualified per their requirements.
But no one was able to actually verify
if he truly was Macau's
bastard because Megara was infamous
for many reasons.
But one of the big ones was that
he was never able to actually sire an heir
with any of the wives that he took.
Neither male nor female.
so it is always possible
that these makers bastard
but a lot of people believe
that he just came
from some other unnamed Targaryen
inside the royal household.
the idea though is because of his age.
He does come from someone who was alive
during make or break,
like some contemporary of make wars
within the royal family.
He winds up trying to claim the sheep
stealer.
One of the wild dragons.
I won't get into spoilers for that,
but it turns into a very tough
kind of punchline.
Like a funny but really WTF kind of moment
for his character
I already did a video
for the other Dragons.
These we learned about most of them,
so I'll link
that video in the description below to
they'll be filming for a while
so we should get some more teasers.
If you spotted any other Easter eggs
or references
in the footage or other new characters
that I didn't mention the video right
then below in the comments,
there will be a bunch more stuff
that they haven't revealed yet.
the big reminder though,
this week, Asoka episodes are starting
and they're airing them a day early.
Now on Tuesdays, my Episode
one video will post late Tuesday night.
My episode to video
will post Wednesday morning.
After that it's going to be weekly,
so be sure to enable alerts my channel
so you don't miss any of that stuff
Click here
for that other House of the Dragon Season
2 teaser for episode
5 and click here for all My House
The Dragon Season 2 Videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!